well can we talk about stonks for a bit
oh god yeah this is hilarious
so gamestop yesterday game stock as of
right now
is up about a hundred bucks the price is
248 dollars per share
up 68 percent from yesterday's clothes
earlier it was above 300.
susan you know what this is all about
take me through the whole story please
social media ching chong ching chong
chong ching
i know it was her own average joe's
she's one of those lh
players and guess what the army of
average joes are winning
so far at least for now but the question
is how long
elon musk even tweeting out his approval
with his tweets
rallying the stock 30 percent in the
after hours
elon musk tweeting game stunk which is
what it's been called on that reddit
wall street bets page
that's been behind the game stop moves
also silicon valley investor
math falafetia says he's bidding
thousands of dollars
on game gamestop with the 115 calls
for the month of february now gamestop
as we know has rallied like crazy they
call this insane
700 this month literally killing the
shorts yeah it's up to 3 30 now
what it's up to it's not even oh my god
honestly i i told royce too when i um
when i got up today i was talking to one
of my buddies who does a lot of trading
stuff
cause like i've always done crypto and
i've got a buddy that's starting to pull
me over into the stock side of things
and he's like are you watching this
gamestop thing and i'm like yeah it's
pretty wild but i haven't had really
time to to keep up with it
so i'm getting ready to come through the
show and i look and i'm like holy [ __ ]
it's at 3 30 now
and i really really badly wanted to
short game stop today
but apparently my my weeble app only
lets me do 100 contracts at a time
so it wanted me to give him like eight
thousand dollars worth of collateral for
it i was like i'm not doing it
like that's way way degenerate i was
going to do some
i was like oh i could like i could short
like
10 shares and then if it goes down you
know i'll make some money but
they want a minimum of 100 and i was
like i'm not giving you people 8 600
dollars to hold
on a [ __ ] game stop bet when these
people are
wildly manipulating this right now like
that could
definitely not go my way very quickly
our buddy steve uh
says this is a 10 year old battle that
started in 2008
during the occupy movement griffin steve
cohen backed melvin capital
now says that they have closed their
shorts
happy villages same both losing money on
that trade
now game stop is worth over 10 billion
dollars at last count that's more than
under armour more than american
airlines and gamestop i would argue was
a perfect target for this type of
cartel of day traders there's huge short
interest in the stock with a double the
actual stock float between the game stop
was going to fall anyway so this is a
rape opportunity kill out the lopsided
short trades
on a company that doesn't have a lot of
stock to trade you call this froth i
call it strategic
okay well i'm not not sure whether we
differ on this but i'm calling it a
casino and i don't like it i think it's
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry when a bunch of
people
when a bunch of people on reddit have
been doing what the [ __ ] these hedge
fund managers have been doing four years
decades they've been doing this
century they are they're so
[ __ ] angry right now they're really
mad that
that pleb the plebian normies are
[ __ ] getting in and [ __ ] their
[ __ ] up they're just so angry
it's very funny by the way somebody said
michael berry um
bought some gamestop a couple months ago
but it's like
okay but like where was that information
six months ago i don't know
i'll let somebody go oh yeah i know
billionaire [ __ ]
billionaire strategist michael berry
bought some six months ago
all right where were you with that why
didn't you burst in here like kramer
from seinfeld six months ago
i am so happy that this is happening
uh so not so remember steve not cia
steve our buddy who's been on the show a
couple times he's really into this stuff
and he says
uh they've had it out since the bailout
silicon valley has decided they know
better than everyone and want to control
everyone so
first they neutered dc with twitter and
then facebook yeah
look i'm happy this is happening i think
it's hilarious
i think it's [ __ ] hilarious because
they have they
nip they manipulate stock all the time
we pretend like insider trading is not
it doesn't happen it happens all the
[ __ ] time they play around with
everything and then when a bunch of
[ __ ] meme lords
who happen to know about stonks go on
reddit and decide to [ __ ] their world
this guy's not the only one
a lot of the financial tv people are
losing their mind they're screaming
they're [ __ ]
their [ __ ] day hate that this is
happening
but guess what you built a system like
this this is how this is the system you
built
and you've been manipulating the system
for a long time and now they're using
this very system
[ __ ] against you and i think it's
hilarious
robin hood crashed yesterday the app
well yeah td ameritrades pulled uh
games gamestop too so they're not even
letting you buy it yeah um or sell it
which is crazy but
um look
this is all fine and good i know it's
funny that
you know they're doing this but i gotta
say this one
very bad timing because we are
we're we're getting into a dangerous
time economically right now so
probably throwing wrenches into the
gears of the stock market
i know i think it's hilarious i just
think the timing is poor
it's poor timing right now because we're
gonna have more than enough money
problems down the road as it is
um the stock market's going to [ __ ]
fall apart
with or without any help so i think just
throwing molotov cocktails into the
stock market right now is probably a
little
a little scary um and the other thing is
here's what's going to happen nothing
like nobody at gamestop is going to get
in trouble nobody anywhere is going to
get in trouble
the people that are doing this are going
to get in trouble that's what they're
not doing anything illegal
they'll find a way let's leave there's a
lot there's a lot of people
in federal prison because they the sec
decided they want to throw him in prison
and they went
i didn't even think what i was doing was
illegal um
i'm just saying there are ways to
when the federal government and when
these people these powers that be get
pissed off
there's ways to [ __ ] you up like you can
go well i'm not doing anything illegal
no that's fine we're just gonna have the
irs audio every three months
oh that's fine we're just gonna have the
sec take your computers for a couple
weeks and
give them back when we feel like it ah
maybe the fbi will be around
trust me when i tell you the people that
are organizing this [ __ ]
they are going to [ __ ] these people up
these people are
not happy you don't get to piss off this
many [ __ ] people that rich
and not end up having people rooting
around your computers and [ __ ] with
your [ __ ]
these people have [ __ ] i'm just
saying man they threw a rock at a
hornet's nest and now they're like oh
[ __ ] i'm telling you they're gonna end
up getting [ __ ] with
jim edwards says they're gonna start
calling them financial terrorists
though they will they will mark my words
jim's saying it is a joke but i think
he's right and steve has a good point
it's
it's gonna hurt gamestop but here's the
thing i don't care if it hurts gamestop
because you know how many trades
gamestop suck me out of you know how
many trades
so also [ __ ] gamestop too while we're at
it i don't care
i just think it's funny when they get a
taste of their own medicine but don't
worry cnn's
i got i got an argument cnn's figured it
out but that's why i wanted to short it
because i wanted to short it at 320 and
then buy it back at like 50 bucks just
like gamestop used to do
oh that'd be perfect best i could do 50
bucks the best i could do is about
38 bucks sorry but i just bought the
game yesterday
but i've been having some bad luck
lately and i just had a feeling i'd be
like yeah right 100
100 puts right now boom and i'd wake up
tomorrow and
be like game stock but 780 dollars i'd
be like
i'm ruined i'll be like the old man from
trading places
well cnn figured it out don't worry uh
this is the article they just wrote
right before the show actually they
figured out what happened with gamestop
cnn is is don't worry they got it how
trumpism explains the game stop stock
search
it's for trump it's trump it's trump and
gamergate
at the core of donald trump's angry
populist appeal
was and is dissent this sentiment the
elites think they know better than you
they think they can tell you how to live
and what to believe but guess what we
people are smarter than the elites now
this article is doing exactly what
people accuse the elites of doing which
is talking down to you
of course so get ready uh what trump uh
what what made trump's argument so
potent politically speaking
is that he wasn't just calling out the
elites he was saying that
average joes need the gym again right
yes
vince vaughn uh and the pirate steve the
pirate uh
needed to rise up and actually show them
how wrong they were
that voting uh voting him for him
was the best way to express their anger
and frustration with the condescension
of their alleged
betrayers donald trump offered himself
up as a collective middle finger to the
elites and he won
all of which brings to the current
seemingly inexp inexplicable
it's it's no no you can explain it we've
already did
stock search of games of gamestop the
video game sell that is
that has made its money over the years
the origins of the search are
in the preventable belief among wall
street sharp professional investors
the gamestop stock even before this
recent spike was overvalued after all
the shopping malls are long in decline
malls are doomed 25 will be gone in five
years read a cnn headline in 2017
that was only been exacerbated by covet
19.
as a result of of the belief among the
pro-investor crowd the gamestop was
essentially doomed they began shorting
the stock essentially betting on it to
fail
this happens all the time to a variety
of stocks with even
with very little fanfare it is a way of
the modern stock market
except this time amateur investors
decided to revolt against the pros using
reddit
and a subreddit known as our wall street
bets the amateurs began a coordinated
effort buying gamestop stock
to drive its price higher and higher
it's worth
noting that reddit was also a gathering
spot for some of the most ardent trump
supporters of 2016.
clearly correlation reddit and trump i
got it
i it's they they will never just be able
to it's it this is the classic principal
skinner like
no it's the children that are wrong and
it's like they they just
can't grasp why we despise them so much
like they don't don't they don't get it
and they're like well clearly it's
trump's fault because i'm awesome
like what's that effort to screw the
pros
people with short positions on a stock
that is surging and have major
vulnerabilities
the higher the stock goes got an
unexpected boost from
one for none other than iconoclast in
chief intel
and tesla founder elon musk who tweeted
gamestonk
with the link to the wall street bet
subreddit on tuesday musk also has been
a long time critic on
social media centering and was a
prominent covert 19 skeptic
sounds like anyone we know trump
uh and there's no question that the
populist revolt was
worked for game stock a game stock game
stop stock
on december 28th it was trading at 20 a
share on wednesday
it was uh under 335 a share
what's the end game for game stop
sergers like
now they have proven the point that they
can take a stock that
the pros have decided to kill and revive
it
i love how they're like now trying to
reverse it okay
you guys made your point they're trying
to do this like a hostage negotiation
all right you got your point your voice
returned how about we let everybody go
now and they're like no
we're not we're holding up in here for a
couple weeks wait till the sec makes
makes reddit take down that [ __ ] page
they will they will trust me a lot of
i'm telling you man
people have been saying like oh this is
great i'm like it is great
but the people doing it are gonna get
deep [ __ ] by the government government
doesn't forget this [ __ ]
and the government is just the
enforcement arm of billionaire
[ __ ] hedge fund guys like they're
gonna make some phone calls and go
i want everyone on that reddit thread
thrown in prison
at least for the moment well what do we
do now because they don't really believe
that gamestop is suddenly the new amazon
or apple or google
it's still mostly a business that
derives its value from brick and mortar
stores and malls
which again is not exactly a big growth
area in the coming years
the point is there's no real point
beyond showing up the pros proving to
them
that they aren't as smart as they think
they are and that they don't have the
ability to control everything which
again has its roots in
trumpism of course uh the white
supremacy
the entire notion of trump's candidacy
and presidency was a stick it to the
elites
and then well there wasn't really a plan
beyond that the screwdriver was the
point now remind remember
the cnn and msnbc have been fighting to
get trump out of the white house
they got trump out of the white house
and all they could do and you've seen it
you look at the news all they could do
is still
just talk about trump because biden's
boring right he's not doing anything
you know he's doing things that are
horrible my point is he's not exciting
so that they're hurt they're hurting
that's not true i've read a bunch of
articles about the white house
i've read about um the parks and rec
producers saying joe biden's a great
actor and he's fun fun on set
i read um other articles about
the the dogs what about biden's dog
these dogs are releasing press releases
a lot of hard-hitting journalism royce
let's not pretend like they're not doing
their job oh and uh how about the one
where hunter biden got munchies and they
had to pull over the motorcade so you
could get a bagel
it's just they do not like i was like
wow we're going back to this now
we're just gonna go back to like how
great is the president
the point is that there's no real point
beyond showing up the pros
proving to them that they aren't as
smart as they think they are and they
don't have the ability to control
everything which
i read that the point is to make you
lose money
the point is to take your money away
like i
i know you think it's that simple really
just trying to stick it
no they're trying to steal your money
from you like you've been doing to
people for [ __ ] decades that's what
they're doing the strategy
if that is even a word that can be
associated with what this is
has massive limits sticking it to the
man will only get you so far it's not a
solution to any problem
it's just a way to express frustration
anger and feelings of helplessness
think of it this way giving someone the
finger might make you feel good at the
moment
but it doesn't solve anything right but
you
this is all you see the reason people
are doing what happened on reddit
is because there's nothing else to do
nobody in congress has wanted to solve
this the stock market's a [ __ ] mess
it's been manipulated for years it's
going to
continue to be manipulated you don't
like this one time
one look at this one time the
average joes that they're calling them
decide to come in and [ __ ]
[ __ ] with you guys and you lose your
[ __ ] you don't know what to do
um so what i mean i don't care what it
does to gamestop gamestop's the perfect
company to do it too if you asked me
they were going under anyway
so you're going to do the somebody do to
someone that's going down anyway but
they they everything is because of trump
this is also because of trump
everything that's going to happen the
next 20 years is because because of
trumpism
these [ __ ] people and they're losing
their minds over this
and again it's like you want to blame
trump because you just can't come to
terms with the fact that just maybe
people hate you like maybe you're just
hateable